pour remettre le grand prix du jury
accueilli à présent mademoiselle agnès
jaoui et monsieur costa gavras
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a dans notre métier de cinéma du
rêve de l'espoir encore des émotions des
idées pauvres imbéciles ou superbe
il ya du dérisoire et de l'immense les
ouvriers de l'art et de l'art d'être
ouvrier il ya la peur il ya le courage
il ya le monde
capturés pour se comprendre pour a tenté
une histoire il ya des les disciplines
au cinéma aussi encore se cabrer et
c'est bien heureux c'est un président
acquia verront décerner le grand prix et
le grand prix est attribué à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à tous
des sites participants
je tiens à dire que je n'ai pas fait ce
film au sol j'ai fait ce film avec toute
une série d'acteurs de techniciens et
producteurs des financeurs des gens qui
m'ont soutenu et que je suis heureux que
ça a été une aventure aussi collectives
pour appeler une histoire qui l'a été
tout autant on n'est jamais aussi
intelligent aussi beau aussi fort que à
plusieurs et ça a été un moment
d'émotion très très fort ce festival
pour moi voilà je tiens à remercier les
gens qui m'ont aidé et tous mes acteurs
tous mes techniciens
je tiens à remercier gilles marchand et
de renconter qui m'ont soutenu dans ce
travail je tiens à remercier philippe
mongeau qui a travaillé sur le scénario
avec moi il ya l'estrade le fondateur
d'act up qui est venu voir le film la
semaine dernière et j'en suis très très
heureux et d'autres copains de l'époque
christoph marthaler vollmann voila voila
et jeu long et évidemment on peut penser
que j'ai ce film est un hommage aux gens
qui sont morts mais c'est aussi un
hommage à ceux qui ont survécu et qui
tiennent encore aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
enfin qui ont eu beaucoup de courage et
auxquels je pense énormément ce soir qui
sont toujours avec des traitements
lourds et avec des situations assez
précaire parce qu'à l'époque où il était
militant ils ont mis un peu leur vie
entre parenthèses voilà c'est à tous à
ceux tous ces gens là que je pense c'est
donc je vous remercie beaucoup merci
beaucoup
ce soir à la palme du coeur de l'immense
majorité des cas ch'ti dany 120
battements par minute est une fresque
sur le quotidien de l'association de
lutte anti sida act up paris au début
des années 90 co scénarise entre les
murs palme d'or 2008 robin campillo
signe avec ce film son troisième long
métrage après les revenants et eastern
boys sans vos battements par minute
sortira le 23 août tout comme les proies
de sofia coppola privée juste avant